okay let's look at the solution what
about optimized app code well that's
about making the code actually run
faster app stats is the best option for
that what about reduced latency for
static content while doing this would
involve reducing the latency to do you
sir a perfect example of edge caching
what about making your app more
responsive all certainly queues could be
an option here to reduce the amount of
time spent when you process the request
but that could also be achieved using
automatic scaling parameters and of
course memcache to serve content from
memory instead of data store what about
reducing data store reads well certainly
memcache would help out here but edge
caching could also be an option if the
content is suitable for that what about
improving performance as user base grows
well that's a clear-cut scaling out
problem so automatic scaling alright I
hope you did well and this quiz has no
exact answers so be sure to discuss this
in the forums as well